how long do you think this disruption
that we're all seeing by public sector
workers is going to last
morning Jonathan well I think the answer
to the question really lies at the doors
of number 10 and number 11 down the
streets I think these strikes could end
tomorrow the government was prepared to
have serious sensible discussions about
pay with our public sector at unions but
so far the government has refused to
negotiate refuse to to compromise so I
think that the the answer to that
question really does lie with Missy
sunak and with Jeremy Hunt and with
other cabinet ministers the last thing
that any public sector worker wants to
do over Christmas or into 2023 is to
take strike action it's a very difficult
thing to do people lose pay they can't
deliver the services that they're proud
to deliver day in day out but they feel
they've got no alternative and it's
really now down to the government to
step up to the plate and negotiate and
yet the strikes are continuing
especially over the crucial Christmas
and New Year periods do you think we are
going to see synchronized strikes in
2023
well as I say the decision to take
strike action is a very difficult
decision no one takes it lightly and I
think we've got a responsibility as a
TUC and as as unions that when workers
do take that difficult decision we
support them as much as possible and
that means in some circumstances
coordinating industrial action and and
that makes sense for example for NHS
unions to talk to each other for
teaching unions to talk to each other
but you know underlying all of these
disputes is the fact that each of those
public sector workers whether they're
paramedics or teachers or firefighters
or physiotherapists have had a real
terms pay cut this year and it really is
time for the government to do the right
thing by their own Workforce to do the
right thing by our public services and
sit down and negotiate a fair settlement
on pay
um Mark so what the General Secretary of
the pcsu uh said to Skye yesterday it's
only a matter of time before we
coordinate strikes he seems to think
it's definitely going to happen
um is that fair comment
well I think Mark was also very clear
that that the government has the
responsibility to end these strikes and
could end the strikes if they sat around
the table and negotiated with our unions
but as I said Jonathan our unions will
be talking continuing to talk into the
new year about how we best support and
coordinate unions that are taking that
strike action in some cases that may
mean Uni's taking strike action on the
same day in other cases it'll be a
rolling wave of industrial action the
key thing is we need to resolve these
disputes and we need to find a way
forward on pay and that's only going to
happen if the government sits down and
negotiates this has happened in the
private sector we've seen unions taking
industrial action in the private sector
and winning really important pay Rises
for workers whether they be bus drivers
or baggage handlers or outsourced
cleaners Now's the Time for the
government to learn that private sector
example and talk to unions yeah you see
the problem for for members of the
public and people watching this program
is that many do have sympathy with
workers who are really struggling like
they are with this cost of living crisis
but when they hear
threats of potential what look might
look like a general strike you may well
lose a lot of that support
well I think the British public are very
clear whose responsibility or who's
responsible for these strikes two-thirds
of the public field the government is
mishandling uh the the strikes and
frankly if you if you put up Richie
sunak Jeremy Hunt and Steve Barkley
against our nurses our paramedics our
firefighters and our posties I know we
decide the British public is on I think
that the public knows the way you
resolve these strikes is to sit down and
reach a compromise and a fair settlement
on pay the only people who don't seem to
realize that at the moment are the
governments and I think they need to
listen to the British public they need
to listen to unions and they need to
listen to the public sector workers
employers who should be sitting down
it's not the government
[Music]
well well certainly in the Public
Services uh the government is the
employer they're the ones who hold the
pair strings and likewise on our
Railways we know for a fact and we know
partly because the TUC and the rmt
launched an uh uh published a legal
opinion on this that the government sets
the parameters uh for those pay
negotiations in rail so the government
can't wash its hands and pretend it has
nothing to do with this they are the
employers they're the ones who see
sitting around the table they're the
ones who need to find money uh to pay a
decent pay rise of public sector workers
can you see it can you see a time in the
next few days the next few weeks where
you Marx maybe Matt rack has been
speaking to us this morning actually all
sit down all have a conversation about
how you can inflict the most amount of
pain
yeah well it's not about inflicting the
most amount of pain
you're going to get hurt isn't it isn't
that what strike actions no because I
no it's about getting the employer to
listen to the to the to the real issues
and concerns of of their own Workforce
and it won't just be uh matter Mark
there'll be people like Christina McAfee
from Eunice and Sharon Graham uh from
unite all of our Public Service unions
have an interest in this and it's
important to make the point as well
remember our members are members of the
public it's our members who use the
trades uh who use hospitals who send
their kids to the state schools and
quite often it's members of the cabinets
who are insulated from those services so
the last thing we want to do is cause
any disruption whatsoever but we do need
the government to listen to the concerns
of their own Workforce just those
private sector employees have done so
over the course of the last few months
there's a way forward here on pay but
it's going to require the government uh
to step up to the plate be mature and
enter into a dialogue
if the government if employers were to
give everyone a double-digit pay rise
that is going to fuel inflation isn't it
and it's going to make life a lot worse
for so many people who are already
struggling with the cost of living in
crisis we don't want it to last longer
than it's going to
yeah but but there is absolutely no
evidence at all that it's the pay of
nurses paramedics and teachers that
drive an inflation in this country I
mean I wish the government was as
concerned about what's happening to
profit so profits up 31 last year alone
dividends handed out to shareholders
Rising three times faster than wages a
bump a year for bonuses in the city of
London and a government that decided to
lift the cap on Bankers bonuses they're
very clear political choices and they're
choices that don't work for working
people their families and communities so
let's do the right thing by those who
are delivering our Public Services let's
make sure they've got money in their
pockets that they can afford to pay
those heating bills to fill the car to
pay for the weekly food shop the rental
mortgages these are the real pressures
our members of under and you know when
over a course of hospitals in this
country have food banks for their own
staff the government has to acknowledge
there's an issue there's a problem here
and it's one that they've got a
responsibilities to solve but it's
whether or not strike action is actually
working we've seen the military uh seem
to be doing a pretty good job standing
in for Border Force officials averting
uh delays at our airports and certainly
many people now have got used to working
from home and not taking the train into
the office they've sort of shrugged
their shoulders and they're just getting
on with life is there an argument that
actually a lot of this strike action
isn't really getting the message that
you want to cross
I I don't think that that argument
Stacks up at all and to be honest with
you the reason why people are going
through our borders so easily is because
those military payers now don't have the
powers to stop people at our borders and
effectively the government has decided
it's going to open the board isn't it I
think rather than getting the uh Army to
cover the jobs of Border Force officials
or indeed ambulance drivers and
paramedics the government will be far
better sitting down and negotiating the
solution to this set of disputes with
unions at the end of the day I I can say
this right from the bottom of my heart
there isn't a single member of the
public sector Workforce that wants to be
taking strike action this Christmas all
of those workers themselves
why are they doing why are they doing on
crucial days though why are they
destroying people's businesses
destroying people's New Year plans after
we've all had two really difficult years
over the festivities because of covid
why choose those days
to make your point
well the reality is our rail service is
often shut down over the Christmas
period anyway for engineering works and
actually the industrial action is
hitting those engineering Works rather
than the traveling public but I don't
know if you've been on the train lately
Jonathan because I certainly have and it
doesn't matter whether there's
industrial action or not we have got a
broken Railway system in this country
it's a privatized fragmented rail system
that's the real reason our trains are
canceled and don't run on time so you
know honestly
I I I'm not interested in driving a
wedge between different groups of
working people our members are members
of the public they rely on those
services and I think they have at the
very least should be treated with
respect by the government to have their
voices listened to and have their
genuine issues and concerns addressed by
governments that frankly is overseeing
chaos on our rails in our hospitals in
our schools it's not good enough for
service users it's not good enough for
staff and it's not good enough for the
public you've just started your new job
I don't know if you've had a chance to
speak to the leader of the opposition
yet but do you feel you're getting
enough support from secure Starman he
doesn't want labor front benches on
picket lines does he
yeah I'm not really interested in
whether or not labor front benches Turn
Up For a selfie on a picket line what
I'm interested in is in labor being an
effective opposition and being a
potential uh alternative government and
going into an election on a Manifesto
that that matters that talks about the
issues that matter to the people that I
represent so when labor says they're
going to ban ban fire and rehire so that
we have no more piano style seconds when
labor says it's going to ban zero hours
contracts and when labor says if the
government brings forward more
legislation to make it harder for people
to take strike action they'll repeal
that legislation that to me sounds like
a good starting point for a future labor
government and one that actually
responds to the issues and concerns of
working people
do you stand by your language that
you've been using in recent days that
the government is sabotaging uh any
chance of sorting this mess out
yeah well I feel that they have been
sabotaging it right from our Railways
where initially uh Minister said they
had no responsibility for those
negotiations at all then had to fess up
that actually they did have a
responsibility they threw in conditions
at the last minute I think they'd scope
of the deal a rail that was within grass
a few weeks ago but but look at look at
what happened last week in the Health
Service in the midst of a pay dispute
Stephen Barkley the health secretary
said he'd talk about anything with
unions except pay I mean that just
doesn't make sense whatsoever and I
think it's a real uh slap in the face
for those those NHS staff who just felt
they had no alternative but to take
strike action so Now's the Time for
governments uh to not act as a barrier
to a settlement but to actually
facilitate the settlement and the only
way they're going to do that is by
sitting around the table and reaching a
compromise and reaching an agreement
all right uh we are out of time we'll
see what the new year brings Paul Novak
new boss of the TUC thank you very much